salut françois re bonjour casimir
hochart 1 juil oui à lui sabrina n'est
pas là non elle m'a demandé de garder la
boutique pour la journée ah bon alors
c'est toi quand je vais voir
alors il faut que tu me prépares vite
bon pâté de campagne avec de la mousse
au chocolat d'accord des rillettes avec
des cornichons et la confiture de
groseilles et des lycées délicieux oui
et alors
aaron les cerises confirmer explique toi
casimir qu'est ce que tu veux que je te
prépares civile deux sandwichs gacoin
livres et bien justement c'est pas
facile pu comprendre quand on part pour
un grand voyage
il n'est pas facile de choisir ses
sandwichs alors je veux des sandwichs
avec du pâté de campagne du beurre de la
mousse au chocolat des saucisses de
strasbourg avec du miel d un rang avec
de la confiture de groseilles des
cornichons d eau dure une tranche
d'ananas mais mais mais mais ça ne
tiendra jamais dans un sandwich tout ça
tu crois en une où ça va couler d'autres
analyses tu tâchera toutes les affaires
mais même dans un grand sandwich ben oui
j'en suis sûr
c'est dommage les émirs parce que ça
arrête tu as bien dit que du parti en
voyage
ouais et alors c'est une grande nouvelle
ça m excuse je vais faire le tour du
monde tour du monde c'est formidable et
en quel honneur pour photographier les
sept merveilles du monde les sept
merveilles du monde mais où est ce
qu'elle se trouve
mais vous n'en avez jamais entendu
parler mais survit demande tout le monde
a entendu parler des sept merveilles du
monde et vous aussi n'est ce pas
seulement peu de gens savent quels sont
ces merveilles
allez les enfants venir et moi je
m'étais bouvier de la voix
voilà sur l'herbe ya de la place pour
tout le monde sauf été installés alors
écoutez moi bien est-ce que vous avez
déjà entendu parler des sept merveilles
du monde
personne y en a qui en ont entendu
parler
oui eh bien je vais vous dire ce que
c'est c'est cette monument que les
anciens trouver les plus beaux du monde
et depuis il y en aurait beaucoup
d'autres
mais quand on parle des sept merveilles
du monde ce sont toujours ceux là qu'on
cite voilà et notre ami casimir valais
les photographier pour nous oui je vais
faire de très belles photos 1
on espère et 10 dont casimir toi au
moins tu les connais les sept merveilles
du monde en est bien sûr oui alors tu
peux vous en citer quelques unes
d'abord il ya le vieux port de marseille
le vieux port de marseille à votre avis
ce n'est pas bon le vieux port de
marseille c'est magnifique mais ça fait
pas partie des sept merveilles du monde
dorian là le zoo de vincennes 2 ou le
zoo de vincennes devant la scène s'est
ralliée nommés ont 10 11 ou alors à
votre avis n'ont pas dit qu'ils n'ont
alors un attend la pointe du raz
comprend la douane du rabotage
non seulement c'est magnifique qu'est ce
que c'est la pointe du raz
c'est un site c'est ainsi marianne a
raison c'est pas un monument c'est pas
un monument
eh bien écoutez moi je vous la donne et
la liste je vais chercher mon livre vi
dont julie tu as mon livre s'il te plaît
à fille blessée
voilà alors les sept merveilles du monde
ce sont sept monument très très vieux
qui ont tous plus de 2000 ans et des
noms très compliqué et malheureusement
pour la plupart ils ont tous disparu
alors il n'y a fait il y avait les
jardins suspendus de sémiramis à
babylone casimir c'est dur on trouverait
à peine la trace au milieu des ruines
bon en numéro 2 il y avait la statue de
zeus le dieu grec par philias un
sculpteur qui vivait il y a plus de 2300
en polar et malheureusement la statue a
disparu numéro 3 la troisième merveilles
du monde
c'était le temple d'artémis à ephèse
en asie mineure ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le proche orient
il a été incendiée il ya plus de 2300 la
4e merveilles du monde
c'était le mausolée d'halicarnasse qui a
été démoli à peu près à la même époque
par les troupes d'alexandre le grand
et puis il y avait une très grande
statue qui s'appelait le colosse de
rhodes
mais figurez vous qu'un tremblement de
terre n'a fait tomber par terre quand on
phare d'alexandrie la 6e merveilles du
monde
ben il s'est écroulé tout seul tu vois
quasiment sur les sept merveilles du
monde
il y en a qu'une seule que tu pourras
voir là qu'il doit photographier c'est
les pyramides d'égypte mais je ne veux
pas photographier les pyramides d'égypte
mais enfin casimir d'une bien dit que je
voulais voir des sept merveilles du
monde
oui mais parce que je croyais que
c'était le vieux port de marseille
le zoo de vincennes la pointe du raz
alors casimir casimir tu ne pars plus
non notre formidable
bon bah là puisque je ne pars plus julie
tu peux me préparer mon sandwich
alors avec une petite campagne de la
mousse au chocolat de la groseille avec
des anchois de la mortadelle avec un
oeuf dur de l'ananas 1 1 ils sont
je vais te le prépare et on s'en doute
si tu ne pars pas mais il faudra au
moins cinq minutes alors tu reviens
merci alors qu'est-ce que j'ai fait du
pâté saucisson corse à moi ce que je
vais m'en sortir je suis content c'est
mon temps je vais à mon sens déjà
comparé à casimir est sécurisé mais oui
c'est toi la huitième merveille du monde
dites moi en quoi
non
[Musique]